Despite the anime industry bringing in over 21 billion dollars in 2019,...
...according to the Association of Japanese Animations poll of animators,...
...for their on average workday of about 12 hours,...
...a number that already shouldn't be scoffed at,...
...50% felt like their wages were insufficient...
...compared to the work that they put in.
In a New York Times article interviewing Tetsuya Akutsu,...
...who's worked as a head animator on episodes of shows like...
..."Darling in the Franxx" and "Made in Abyss,"...
...he claimed to earn about 1,400 dollars to 3,800 dollars a month,...
...or about 17,000 to 46,000 a year, as a top animator.
Because of how much time he has to devote daily to the job...
...and the financial instability, he acknowledges that...
"It's impossible to get married and to raise a child...
...as an animator in Japan."
It's almost as if you can't even have your own life.
And even though a range of 17,000 to 46,000 is nothing to be scoffed at,...
...compared to his American counterparts in animation,...
...this pales in comparison to their average of 65,000 a year or more.